[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir ces attaques djihadiste
au mali deux casques bleus de la
minustah ont été tués lundi près de
mopti dans le centre du pays ce week-end
ce sont quarante soldats de l'armée
malienne qui périssaient dans une
attaque paris a de son côté annoncé ce
lundi la mort de yahia djouadi un chef
historique d'aqmi dans le nord du mali
nous serons à bamako dans ce journal le
premier conseil des ministres du
président du burkina faso le
lieutenant-colonel damiba l'a présidé ce
lundi pour une prise de contact avec les
nouveaux ministres du cabinet nommé ce
week-end enfin nous irons en guinée où
l'inflation galope depuis le coup d'état
du 5 septembre dernier la hausse des
prix devient compliqué pour les familles
guinéennes la moitié d'entre elles
vivent déjà en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté reportage à suivre
deux casques bleus de la minustah la
mission des nations unies au mali ont
été tués lundi près de mopti dans le
centre du pays vendredi toujours dans le
centre du pays 40 membres des femmes à
les forces armées maliennes ont péri
dans une attaque jihadiste
dans le même temps ce lundi le ministère
français des armées a annoncé la mort
d'un des chefs d'aqmi al qaïda au
maghreb islamique la correspondance à
bamako n'influant lespiau
yahia djouadi alias abou ammar de
nationalité algérienne était en haut
cadres et combattants expérimentés du
groupe jihadiste al qaïda au maghreb
islamique qui mettait notamment le
conseiller militaire d'abdelmalek
droukdel tués par les forces françaises
le 3 juin 2020 après la libye où yahia
djouadi devient émirs d'aqmi en 2015 ils
s'installent dans la région de
tombouctou au nord du mali où il sert de
coordinateur financier et logistique à
partir de 2019 sa mort intervient après
l'annonce le 17 février du retrait de la
force française barque anomalies l'armée
française opèrera désormais depuis le
niger et se concentrera sur
l'élimination de hauts cadres jihadistes
pour tenter d'affaiblir ces
organisations qui continuent de gagner
du terrain au mali et plus largement au
sahel une avancée que tente de freiner
les forces de sécurité maliennes cette
dernière semaine les femmes a soutenu
par une large partie de la population
ici on communiquait sur la montée en
puissance des militaires maliens des
militaires qui n'ont cependant pas été
épargnés ce vendredi par une attaque
terroriste dans le centre du pays hamon
d'oro où d'après l'armée malienne 27
militaires auraient perdu la vie lors de
l'attaqué de leur camp dans une zone
considérée aujourd'hui comme l'épicentre
du conflit au mali et le niger n'a pas
été non plus épargné par ces attaques
djihadistes cinq soldats ont été tués
vendredi dans l'explosion d'une mine
artisanale à taureaux 10 dans le sud
ouest du pays une zone où les attaques
terroristes aux engins explosifs se
multiplient les explications de notre
correspondant à niamey harold girard ces
engins explosifs improvisés sont la
véritable hantise des forces armées
régulières qui luttent au quotidien
contre les djihadistes nous n'avons pas
beaucoup plus de précisions sur les
circonstances du drame de vendredi mais
ce que nous savons pour l'instant c'est
que les cinq nigériens qui ont perdu la
vie dans cette attaque faisait partie de
la force ni à une force d'un peu plus de
2000 hommes qui a été créée et mise en
place en février 2022 il y a de cela à
peine un mois et qui est censé contenir
les assaillants sur le territoire
nigérien qui opère entre le nord du
burkina faso et la région sud ouest du
niger je me trouve actuellement aux
abords de la route principale qui mène
de niamey jusqu'au nord du burkina faso
et inversement une route qui a eu
pendant des années un succès au niveau
des commerçants au niveau des habitants
qui traversaient la frontière pour leurs
activités mais qui aujourd'hui au fur et
à mesure que l'insécurité progresse et
bien et de moins en moins fréquentées
évidemment aujourd'hui pour faire le
trajet est bien une escorte militaire
est obligatoire
au burkina faso le président le
lieutenant colonel damiba a présidé ce
lundi son premier conseil des ministres
une prise de contact avec le nouveau
gouvernement
cette nouvelle équipe composée de 25
ministres dans six femmes est dirigé par
le premier ministre albert ouédraogo
économistes 52 ans je vous propose de
l'écouter
j'appelle l'ensemble
des burkinabè
de tous bords a soutenu le nouveau
gouvernement das un moment difficile et
dans la mise en oeuvre de cette vision
des lectures que le président du faso
veut impulser à la gouvernance
d'ensemble
cette dualité la lutte contre le
terrorisme la restauration du territoire
la refondation de l'état
l'amélioration de la gouvernance
la réconciliation nationale et la
cohésion sociale
la prise en charge
et la réinstallation des déplacés
internes dans leurs localités
respectives
un premier groupe de 415 nigérian ayant
fui l'invasion russe en ukraine ont été
rapatriées vendredi dans leur pays
depuis à la capitale roumaine le
gouvernement du nigeria a récemment
annoncé avoir débloqué plus de 7
millions d'euros pour le rapatriement
d'environ 5000 ressortissants nigérians
installés en ukraine rambert stecher
arrivée sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
international d'abuja
ces étudiants nigérians porte encore
leurs écharpes et leurs bonnets
visiblement soulagé ceux qui ont vécu le
début de l'offensive russe en ukraine
racontent leur expérience traumatisante
mais beaucoup d'artillerie lourde de
missiles de bombes ce que tout ça là où
j'étais il n'y avait que de la
destruction mon école partout c'est
terrible c'était vraiment terrible nous
ne pouvions pas rester là 1 800 élèves
cross du collège fédère plus de 400
ressortissants nigérians sont arrivés au
puy bucarest dans un vol affrété par
leur gouvernement la plupart ont mis des
jours à se rendre en roumanie depuis
l'ukraine et témoigne de traitement
raciste aux frontières empêché de monter
dans des bus ou des trains par les
forces de sécurité certains ont dû
marcher pendant des heures dans un froid
glacial alors que les témoignages de
discrimination aux frontière ukrainienne
afflux l'union africaine et l'onu ont
fait part de leurs inquiétudes à kiev
face à la controverse les autorités
ukrainiennes ont annoncé l'ouverture
d'un numéro d'urgence destiné aux
étudiants étrangers souhaitant quitter
le pays
dans la seule actualité en bref et en
images l'algérie qui rassure ses
citoyens sur ses stocks de blé le pays
pourrait tenir jusqu'à la fin de l'année
gros exportateurs l'algérie tente de
faire face aux conséquences de la guerre
en ukraine le blé à échéance de mai 2022
a dépassé les 400 euros la tonne
modern arts annonce la construction de
sa première usine africaine de vaccins
au kenya le fabricant américain de
vaccins signés avec naïrobi un accord
préalable qui prévoit la production de
500 millions de doses par an
l'entreprise ensemble un entend investir
460 millions d'euros dans cette usine
qui produira des vaccins arn messagers
comptes locaux vides 19 pour l'ensemble
du continent en libye si la compagnie
nationale de pétrole a annoncé dimanche
la suspension de la production
pétrolière de deux gisements majeurs une
des vision prise après la fermeture par
un groupe armé des vannes acheminant le
brut sur les sites d'achats rara et d'el
feel cette fermeture cause d'importantes
pertes pour le pays très dépendant de la
vente d'hydrocarbures est empêtré dans
une crise politique importante
et au nigeria les gosses plus
précisément capitale économique du
premier producteur de pétrole du
continent la pénurie de carburant
continue de provoquer des files
d'attentes interminables devant les
stations d'essence obligeant incertain
elle passait la nuit regarder
dans cette station service en plein
coeur de les gosses la circulation est
au point mort des dizaines de
conducteurs frustré disent faire la
queue depuis l'aube en attendant de
pouvoir faire le plein
désert où nous sommes censés travailler
on n'est pas à faire la queue à la
station service et après on passe encore
des heures dans les embouteillages
depuis plus d'un mois le plus grand
producteur de pétrole d'afrique fait
face à de graves pénuries d'essence
car malgré ses importantes réserves d'or
noir
le nigeria ne dispose pas des capacités
suffisantes pour le raffiner et importe
la majorité de son carburant une
politique de subvention a été mis en
place dans les années 70 pour réguler le
prix de l'essence mais elles coûtent
chaque année des milliards d'euros au
gouvernement et a rendu le pays encore
plus vulnérables aux pénuries alors que
les prix flambent sur le marché noir
nombre de nigérians se retrouve en
difficultés économiques dans un pays où
le carburant reste la principale source
d'énergie
mais moi je ne vais pas au marché noir
j'en ai juste besoin pour mon générateur
et pour cause
selon les autorités la pénurie actuelle
aurait été causé par le retrait du
marché d'une importante quantité
d'essence frelatée la compagnie
pétrolière nationale nigériane assure
avoir pris des mesures pour ravitailler
les stations service le plus rapidement
possible
et avant de se quitter en part en guinée
depuis le coup d'état du 5 septembre
dernier les prix ne cessent de flamber à
titre d'exemple le sable de farine a
augmenté de près de 20% une inflation
qui s'explique selon les importateurs
par la hausse des tarifs douaniers pour
les familles guinéennes dont la moitié
vit déjà en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
la situation est de plus en plus
difficile reportage à conakry de sarah
sakho et manning diakité
coronthie un quartier très populaire en
plein coeur de conakry c'est ici
qu'habitent hadja tout bangoura cette
mère de trois enfants et femmes au foyer
et ces derniers temps elle tenait à
faire bouillir la marmite familiale
le nouveau président nous avait promis
qu'à partir du mois de janvier les prix
allaient baisser sur le marché mais les
choses ne font qu'empirer souvent deux
jours passant que j'ai pu préparer un
repas tellement ça difficile avec vingt
mille francs guinéens soit 0 marché
n'arrive plus à cuisiner un plat riz le
sucre la farine ou encore l'huile en
guinée ce sont tous les prix des denrées
de première nécessité qui ont augmenté
ces derniers mois
au grand marché de madina saikou diallo
qui importe entre autres du riz en
provenance d'asie lance un appel aux
nouvelles autorités il faut que
[Musique]
le peuple au niveau du pauvre hère au
milieu de l'album
du côté des autorités on explique avoir
conscience des difficultés traversées
par les guinéens selon le porte parole
du gouvernement des ajustements sont en
cours nous essayons de faire des efforts
dans tous les sens de façon à ce que la
baisse que les guinéens vont constater
sur le panier ne soit pas seulement
conjoncturel mais que ce soit durable
malgré
lardoise que nous avons trouvé plus de
4000 milliards de déficit de n'être les
guinéens s'inquiète déjà d'une possible
hausse supplémentaire des prix à la
proche du ramadan qui débute dans moins
d'un mois
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition ses liens
karacena merci à vous pour votre
fidélité rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]